so there's this fantastic Wikipedia list
descriptively titled Wikipedia : unusual
articles I just remember it as that
Wikipedia list it's a collection of
hundreds of articles about unusual
unexpected and unbelievable subjects no
matter what link you click it's bound to
be interesting for that reason every
week I'm going to click on a new link
and teach you a little bit more about
our amazing world McDonald's is
everywhere in the contiguous United
States the farthest you can get away
from one is a spot in the Sheldon
National antelope Refuge in Nevada even
then you only have to drive 115 miles to
the nearest Golden Arches around the
world there are more than 36,000
locations in 119 different countries one
of the defining characteristics of
McDonald's is a commitment to
consistency across the brand while there
are regional differences to the menu
such as Kiwi burgers in New Zealand or
chicken congee in Indonesia the core
menu items such as Big Macs chicken
nuggets and fries are always available
that means that the same items are being
made in the same way with the same
ingredients in very different economies
around the world obviously Big Macs
don't cost the same everywhere a Big Mac
costs on average 479 in the US so if
you're charged the equivalent in Kenya
480 shilling nobody would buy it because
that's double the average daily salary
that'd be like charging 200 dollars for
a Big Mac in the US that's why
McDonald's sets the local price for
burgers based on a variety of factors
such as labor costs rent ingredient
costs and local income levels now for
some real economics purchasing power is
the amount of goods you can get for one
unit of currency let me explain in the
US the average price of a Big Mac across
all markets is 479 in Sweden the cost of
a Big Mac is 44 Crona 44 Crona is
equivalent to 5 dollars and 13 cents
that means that in the u.s. you can get
20.8% of a big mac for a dollar
while in Sweden you can only get 19.5%
of that burger so in terms of the Big
Mac the purchasing power of the US
dollar is high
you get more bang for your buck this
also means that the Swedish Krona is
overvalued in terms of exchange rates by
about 6.1 percent at least according to
the Big Mac index The Economist magazine
first created the index in 1986 as an
informal way of comparing purchasing
power between currencies so now let's
look at the numbers in Venezuela the
cost of a Big Mac is equivalent to 66
cents that's the cheapest Big Mac in
terms of equivalent US dollars in the
world this is largely due to recent
currency devaluations and high inflation
in the country it's possible that the
cost of a Mena's Weiland Big Mac will
soon rise in response this means that
for the cost of one American Big Mac you
could buy seven Venezuelan Big Macs
after Venezuela the countries with the
cheapest Big Macs are Russia Ukraine
South Africa and Malaysia for the other
side of the spectrum the top 5 most
expensive Big Macs come from Switzerland
Sweden Norway the US then Denmark that's
right the u.s. is home to the fourth
most expensive Big Mac in the world
what's also interesting is to look at
how long it takes individuals to earn
enough money to buy a Big Mac in
different cities around the world in
Nairobi Kenya an average worker would
have to rack up a hundred and
seventy-three minutes on the clock to
pay for one Big Mac compare that to a
worker in Hong Kong who would only have
to work for 8.7 minutes for a burger the
quickest one can earn a burger in the US
is in Miami where the average individual
would only have to work for ten point
seven minutes to pay for a Big Mac now
this index isn't perfect while the cost
of ingredients is pretty similar across
all countries since all ingredients are
held the same standard the index doesn't
account for the wide differences in
labor and land costs a burger will cost
less to make in India because McDonald's
doesn't need to pay as much for
employees and retail space nevertheless
this index is a great way of teaching
some basic economics in a tasty way
I hope you enjoyed this week's episode
last week I covered time keeping on Mars
which you can find here if you enjoy
these videos make sure to click
Subscribe here also please follow me on
twitter app Wendover pro thanks for
watching and I'll see you next week with
more of that Wikipedia list
[Music]